tehát hogy hétköznapi helyzetekben
történő kihágásokért ne legyen az a
büntetés hogy elvesszük a telefont vagy
nincs internet satöbbi ez is lehet ugy a
tiltott gyümölcs a aek igen igen és
ezzel abba az irányba terelhetjük a
dolgot hogy ha eddig mondjuk
kialakítottunk valamilyen bizalmi
közeget akkor a félelem miatt hogy hogy
hogy fél attól hogy elveszik a
telefonját nem fog merni megosztani
például olyan dolgokat hogy zaklatták és
erre egy 2018-as euits online kutatás is
van ahol romániai gyerekeket is kér ztek
és ott is kiderült hogy nagyon sok
gyerek azért nem meri elmondani a
szüleinek hogy mondjuk nyíltan szexuális
tartalmakat kapott vagy zaklatták őt az
online térbe mertogy attól félnek hogy
az lesz a következménye hogy elveszik a
telefonjukat tehát hogy valahogy ezeket
a mondatokat próbáljuk meg valami mással
helyettesíteni